suddenly you investigate yourself new
theories going taking some of Eric's
ideas I understand and to your own and
as we mentioned earlier in your your
favorite model they are still a particle
in there yes at least you could
interpret it this way so I have not
written a paper with Eric but I read a
paper or I tried to read it and while I
was reading the paper I was reminded of
a passage from Stephen Weinberg spoke
dreams of a final theory where he
describes that there are two types of
theoretical physicists there are the
CEOs and the Mystics and the CEOs are
the ones who make an argument
straightforwardly
go from A to B to C and everything one
follows after the other and you can very
easily follow their argumentation and
the Mystics they assemble a cloud of
facts which they lay out and then a
miracle happens and out comes the result
and I think that Eric's is definitely of
the second kind and I had a hard time
making sense of the paper so I said I
would try to put this into a more
digestible form and I found
interestingly two things one is that he
says he needs to start with dark energy
and then dark matter is a consequence
from this so I find that if you try to
write it down in a rigorous mathematical
way you actually get both together so
you do not you do not need to start with
assuming that dark energy is there but
they're both parts of the same story
Eric did not write it down in the
rigorous mathematical way something you
need there's a starting point I mean I
mentioned this that if you want to
really make things mathematically
rigorous we we haven't found the model
yet for our actual universe at positive
dark energy the people that are working
my fieldwork have to work in this
fictitious universe with a negative
cosmological to be mathematically
rigorous but mathematical rigour or very
medical medical precise things can
sometimes be
even comes to constraining so I laid out
a number of ideas and assumptions and
from there on I started reasoning I
think mathematically precise in the
sense that the steps are mathematically
precise but I have to make also some
hypotheses in there which I'm motivated
from a certain intuition so physics
cannot be started from no assumptions at
all and then just reasoning you have to
make some hypotheses and then continue
and then that's that's what I wrote down
is mathematically precise but it's based
on certain assumptions now one could be
forgiven for thinking okay twenty years
ago we could have had a very similar
debate quite the same we doing that
Varick theory for example twenty years
ago but nonetheless there was evidence
for dark matter cosmological evidence
evidence based on the fact on that how
light bends in under gravitational
influence and also already somewhat we
didn't really touch that very much on
dark matter evidence and cosmic
microwave background and early structure
formation of the universe which also
touches onto the dark energy side a
little bit so why haven't we moved on
libido yes I'm happy to say something
about it but I feel like I should add
something here because I think that some
of you might be missing a piece of the
story because up to now you might have
gotten away with the impression that
Eric's model actually explains it all so
why are we even discussing this the
point is of course that it does not
there are some observations that at
least that presently cannot explain for
example the structure that we see in a
cosmic microwave background this is just
something where for which particle Dark
Matter works very very well but that at
least presently cannot be explained with
modified gravity and there are also some
problems with other observations so this
is why there is still a debate in the
community right so just one is ought to
be on the same table now the issue about
why we haven't made progress one of the
reasons why this hypothesis of protocol
Dark Matter became so widely adapted was
that
thirty years ago or so theoretical
physicists had a lot of other reasons to
believe in the existence of additional
particles that conveniently enough also
could make up dark matter for example
there there is an extension of our
current theories that is called
supersymmetry in which you get a lot of
additional particles some of which just
have the right properties to make up
dark matter and this certainly land a
lot of credibility to this hypothesis
now people have looked for these
particles since the mid 80s with
increasingly higher precision you know
larger detectors and better apparatuses
and they haven't found any and now the
most recent round of experiment just
concluded and I think there's now you
know some sense in the community where
people are asking yourself how far do we
really want to push this like do we want
to continue building larger and larger
detectors forever trying to hope to find
this particle which may not even be
there did you know that the institute of
arson ideas also has a podcast
philosophy for our times brings you the
biggest ideas from the leading thinkers
around the world every week search for
philosophy for our times and subscribe
today on your favorite podcast platform
SoundCloud or iTunes to make sure you
never miss an episode